women police language to the point that
we cannot communicate anymore so just
something I noticed so women complain so
this is this could be a series called
women complaining again now guys just as
a prerequisite this is not me saying I
am better than any woman this is not me
you know trying to put women down but
rather to really point out what our true
nature is and that is to complain and
just never be happy if left unchecked
that's that's the key if left unchecked
so what I noticed in the space is women
will interpret things in motion before
logically so what I've noticed is phrase
is like and I mind you I used to do this
at one point and then I realized so when
men communicate they really communicate
to get the point across so oftentimes
women will say it's how you say it in
your tone